mathieu plestan bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors pour bien
comprendre qu'on vient d'entendre un des
australiens de ciney leur joie après ce
déconfinement ce n'est pas toute
l'australie qui est concerné 1
aujourd'hui nos volumes de toute
l'australie n'est pas n'est pas
concernée c'est uniquement la la ville
de sydney et à
sabran de sa grande banlieue qui est
qu'ils étaient confinés dans certains
certains territoires comme par exemple à
la tasmanie on n'a quasiment pas entendu
parler de confinement tout comme la
partie ouest de l'australie le
l'australie occidentale
donc c'est vraiment sydney qui revit un
petit peu qui revit sous certaines sur
certaines conditions mais mais qui revit
à kirby et je pense que tout le monde en
avait bien besoin vous sentez un retour
à la vie d'avant est ce que les bars les
restaurants font le plein
non non pas vraiment une retour à la vie
d'avant s'il ya toujours pas mal de
restrictions qui sont qui sont en place
on en est très très loin ça fait du bien
de pouvoir en sortir de pouvoir aller au
restaurant oui certes mais là la ville
évidemment ne va pas reprendre avant
avant bien longtemps on a quand même pas
mal de restriction la sydney gj bulls et
une attendait monchy c'est une personne
pour quatre mètres carrés à l'extérieur
et une personne pour deux mètres carrés
à l'extérieur donc on est très loin d'un
retour à la vie d'avant qu'en est il des
personnes non vaccinées puisque les
personnes qui peuvent retourner dans les
bars les restaurants sont celles
uniquement qui sont vaccinés pour celles
qu'ils ne sont pas elles ne peuvent
toujours pas sortir de chez elle non non
non il n'y a pas donné
on est vaccinés à 100% ou on ne l'est
pas y aller restrictions elles sont
évidemment très dur pour pour toutes les
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés
l'australie quand même un pays assez
assez protecteur de c2c de ces personnes
est quand même assez
essayent de protéger au mieux toutes
toutes ces personnes donc si on n'est
pas vacciné malheureusement on peut peut
pas sortir c'est dur c'est très dur mais
mais mais ses effets des mesures prises
par le gouvernement même même des
personnes qui ont reçu une seule dose ne
sont pas ne sont pas autorisés à
faire quoi que ce soit de mal
heureusement donc c'est assez assez
réducteur de des libertés de ces
personnes là mais me voilà le
gouvernement essaie de faire campagne
pour que toutes les personnes puissent
se faire vacciner mais du coup quel type
de contrôle sont mis en place pour faire
respecter cette règle ça veut dire que
vous pouvez être contrôlés à tout moment
dans la rue on peut vous demander une
justification de vaccination
n'ont pas spécialement pas spécialement
il ya c'est le problème n'y a pas de
contrôle qui est qui est fait en ce
moment sur sa alors un passeport
sanitaire qui va être mise en place
d'ici et d'ici quelques semaines pour
vérifier quelles sont les personnes
vaccinées quelles sont les personnes qui
ne sont pas vaccinés mais actuellement
on scanne plus mais si c'est pas
toujours plus pour reprenez les ondes de
de contrôler les personnes avant
l'entrée dans des établissements mais
non il n'y a pas de vraiment de de
contrôle qui sont qui sont effectués de
la part de qui que ce soit alors donc
c'est cette règle rhin c'est très dur a
alors on le disait des mesures très
drastiques en australie
des oppositions aussi qu'ils ont qui ont
été réprimées assez fortement est ce que
tout cela susciter le débat dans la
presse locale à la télé sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'il y à des collectifs
qui se mobilisent contre ces décisions
il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de protestations effectivement
ces derniers ces derniers temps
notamment à melbourne qui n'en peut plus
tout simplement ils sont plus de 250
jours de confinement donc effectivement
les personnes n'en pouvait plus et et il
souhaite qu'une seule chose c'est que
tout cela se termine alors sahel les les
images en parler d'elle même il ya eu
des dégâts il ya eu plein de nains de
débordements et ça fait ça a fait
effectivement le la lune de certaines de
certaines éditions mais aujourd'hui on
est plus ici dans le victoria où je me
situe on est plus à comment combattre et
comment faire baisser la courbe le
victoria qui a encore connu plus de 1200
nouveaux cas ces dernières 24 heures
donc actuellement on est plus sur
comment faire pour sortir de 2,7 cette
situation tous ensemble on le précise à
un déconfinement à sydney certes mais
les écoles qui elle reste toujours fermé
c'est bien cela oui alors les écoles
sont toujours fermés certaines écoles
sont ouvertes pour les plus pour les
cultivent et tout ce qui est les classes
moyennes comme le collège par exemple ou
le lycée et même les universités les
universités sont sont toujours à sont
toujours fermés oui et qu'en est il pour
ceux qui souhaitent voyager hors de
l'australie qu'en est il des liaisons
aériennes si vous voulez revenir en
france par exemple est ce que vous
pouvez aujourd'hui alors moi oui je peux
mais je ne pourrai pas retourner en
australie même si mon visa se termine
l'année prochaine je pourrai toujours si
je rend si je prends la décision de
rentrer en france il y aura pas de
retour en australie en revanche on
pourra voyager à la drass a alors
certaines destinations à partir de début
novembre à début novembre certains
certaines destinations ou couvrir comme
la nouvelle zélande
londres le royaume uni les états unis
avec los angeles san francisco certaines
destinations en asie alors à tous
la thaïlande semble que j'ai vu
récemment la thaïlande et dubaï et
aidera ce sont actuellement les toutes
les destinations qui seront 1 qui sont
pourra voyager mais elle n'est pas à pas
dans d'autres dans d'autres destinations
et encore une fois il parlait ici de
bali en indonésie
donné dit qu'il n'est pas encore l'heure
du jour parce que beaucoup australiens
préfèreraient voyage beaucoup en
indonésie merci beaucoup mathieu plestan
pour tous ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste indépendant et
vous habite elle dans la ville de
geelong en australie